à
saint paul au bout de la rue eugène
dayot se trouve l'école du même nom
un établissement où résonnent de joyeux
cris d'enfants une école face à l'océan
est ce pour mieux rappeler la vie de
jeunes d'ayo
vous avez qui était le gêne d'ailleurs
mais pas du tout dans l'histoire suit
non c'est le nom de mon libraire jedi ou
non les grands messieurs où je crois je
sais c'était quelqu'un de sympa d'être
quelqu'un qui a écrit un très beau être
content ouais je crois qu'il est enterré
n'ajuste soutière marin je ne savais
même pas ce
jeune de yuma diego signalé rue jean n'a
pas pris
c'est un écrivain réunionnais célèbre
c'était un poète un poète réunionnais ne
savait pas non plus je vais essayer de
me renseigner quand même
si je vous dis la hache le mutiler ça ne
vous dit rien 20 ans et mutilés voilà
quelle est ma part à ce large festin des
élus d'ici bas qui me dira pourquoi je
me suis qu'un hasard la vie est une fête
où je ne m'associe pas c'est avec sévère
qu un jeune écrivain atteints de la
lèpre marqué la littérature réunionnaise
joachim löw randy eugène dayot est né à
saint pol le 8 août 1810 ce charmant
matheux destiné à une brillante carrière
dans les ponts et chaussées contracte
l'incurable maladie lors d'un séjour à
madagascar chez son père
dès lors il passera les 22 années de sa
lente agonie à écrire
poète romancier ou journalistes il
s'illustre avec le mutiler et la hache
et surtout avec un roman qui paraît sous
forme de feuilleton dans le courrier de
saint paul en 1848
son bourbon pittoresque aborde des
questions comme l'abolition de
l'esclavagé où la peine de mort
eugène dayot le dandy ravagé par la
lèpre meurt en 1852 il n'a que 42 ans
son oeuvre laisse une trace celle du
marronnage présenté comme un
contre-pouvoir au colonialisme